Este problema dice lo siguiente,
el volumen de una caja
es de 405 unidades cúbicas,
el largo de la caja tiene
"x" unidades
y el ancho de la caja tiene
"x" más 4 unidades
y su altura
es de 9 unidades.
En unidades ¿Cuáles son las dimensiones de la caja?
Y bueno me dicen unidades cúbicas
pero pueden ser centímetros, metros, este...
kilómetros cúbicos, no lo sé,
pero son unidades cúbicas por que estamos hablando de que estamos en 3 dimensiones,
porque queremos el volumen de una caja.
Así que déjenme dibujarla
y déjame poner lo que tenemos.
Tenemos que el largo de la caja vale "x"
así que voy a suponer que este es el largo,
el ancho de la caja es "x" más 4
así que este es "x" más 4
y su altura vale 9
y además nos dicen que
queremos saber las dimensiones de la caja
y que el volumen de la caja es de
405 unidades cúbicas.
Entonces déjame ponerlo así,
no, no, no...
mejor déjame ponerlo así
¿Cómo sacamos el volumen de una caja?
Pues es ancho
que es "x" más 4
que multiplica al largo
que es "x"
y esto a su vez,
multiplica al alto que es 9
entonces me queda "x" más 4,
por "x" por 9,
y esto tiene que ser igual ç
pues al volumen de la caja,
¿cuánto vale el volumen de la caja?
El volumen de la caja es 405 unidades cúbicas.
Y lo que tenemos que hacer
es resolver esta ecuación para "x"
pero si te das cuenta, lo primero que quiero que veas
es que esta ecuación
no está igualada a 0 por lo tanto,
primero voy a multiplicar 9 por "x"
y me quedan 9x
que multiplica a "x" más 4 es igual a 405,
después voy a distribuir este 9x
por el bx más 4,
me queda 9x cuadrada más 36x
igual a 405
y para igualarla a 0,
lo que voy a hacer
es restar de ambos lados
de la ecuación 405.
Recuerda que cuando tenemos
una ecuación cuadrática,
la mejor forma de resolverlo
es igualarla a 0
por lo tanto -405, -405
y aquí me va a quedar 0
¡Perfecto! Es justo lo que queríamos
y del lado izquierdo me queda
9x cuadrada más 36x menos 405,
y bueno, ahora,
¿cómo resuelvo esta ecuación cuadrática?
Si te das cuenta
todos estos números son divisibles entre 9,
por lo tanto voy a dividir todo entre 9
405 entre 9? Déjame hacerlo por acá arriba, para ver que nos queda de dividir
pero
¿cuánto es 405 entre 9? ¿Cuál es el resultado?
9 va a dividir a 405
y dice así,
40 entre 9 es 4
4 por 9 es 36 y sobran 4 entonces 36,
y van a sobrar 4 y bajo el 5,
y después me queda 45
cabe 5 veces en 9
5 por 9 es 45 y si lo resto me queda 0,
es exacta como les decía.
Entonces todo esto es divisible entre 9
y esto es lo mismo que poner 9
que multiplica a "x" cuadrada...
no esperen, esperen, esperen...
Creo que hay una forma
mucho más fácil de resolver esto.
Voy a dividir todo entre 9,
en lugar de factorizar el 9
entre 9, entre 9, entre 9 y entre 9,
es decir me estoy ahorrando un paso,
por que si yo factorizara el 9,
lo único que iba a hacer, era tardarme 2 pasos más,
así que mejor de una vez.
Divido todo entre 9,
9 entre 9 se va y me queda "x" cuadrada.
Quiero que veas que estoy dividiendo todo entre 9,
la idea es para simplificar las cosas,
porque factorizar
9x cuadrada más 36x menos 405
no se ve nada sencillo,
sin embargo si divido todo entre 9,
se ve mucho más fácil de resolver esta ecuación,
me va a quedar,
"x" cuadrada más 4x por menos 45 igual a 0.
Y por lo tanto
para factorizar esta ecuación,
tengo que preguntarme
por 2 números los cuales sumados,
me van a dar 45,
sumados o restados,
y la multiplicación de ellos
me va a dar -45,
y bueno 45 lo podemos factorizar
en 45 y una,
¿en quién más?
3 por 15
pero 3 por 15 no me funciona mucho,
y 9 y 5 sí,
9 y 5.
Por que si a 9 le quitamos 5
ó a 5 le quitamos 9
me da un 4
y 9 por 5 me da 45.
Sólo hay que poner
1 positivo y 1 negativo,
por lo tanto me va a quedar
"x" más 9 por "x" menos 5 igual a 0.
Fíjate que el 9 tiene que ser el positivo, para que mi resultado de mi suma de 9 más menos 5 me dé positivo
que tiene que ser 4,
9 menos 5 es 4 positivo
y 9 por menos 5 es -45
y entonces,
tengo 2 binomios igualados a 0,
y recuerden que esto quiere decir que
o el primer binomio es igual a 0,
ó en su dado caso
el segundo binomio es igual a 0.
2 números multiplicados me dan 0
si el primero es 0
ó el segundo es 0,
y después voy a resolver
para cada uno de ellos.
En el primero me queda que "x" es igual a -9,
en el segundo voy a sumar
5 en ambos lados, y me va a quedar
que "x" es igual a 5,
y ya con esto resolví para "x".
Ya sé cuáles son los valores
de las raíces de esta ecuación cuadrática
"x" igual a -9 y "x" igual a 5.
Ahora,
¿qué "x" tomo?
Podría tomar "x" igual a -9,
pero si te das cuenta,
si yo pongo -9 en este cubo,
me va a quedar que un lado vale -5
que el otro lado vale -9,
mientras que la altura vale 9
y eso está muy raro,
porque no tenemos distancias negativas,
yo no puedo hacer un cubo
que tenga de lado -5 ó -9
por lo tanto,
ésta no es opción.
Me voy a quedar con la otra
porque en éste me van a salir resultados positivos,
"x" mas 4 es lo mismo que
5 más 4 que es 9,
el otro lado va a medir 5
y la altura va a medir 9
y ya con esto
tengo las dimensiones de la caja.
Son 9 unidades de ancho,
éste era el ancho,
5 unidades de largo,
5 unidades de largo
y 9 unidades de altura,
y vamos a comprobar que en efecto
esto me da 405,
9 por 5 es 45
y 45 por 9,
lo tenemos aquí arriba es 405.